okay I hope that you have been
participating in the discussions on the
david pakman show reddit more than
18,000 of our viewers and listeners now
regularly participating there you can
find it at david pakman.com slash read
it that's our EDD i.t there is a post
about alex jones conspiracy theorist
alex jones being arrested on a drunk
driving charge I didn't feel it
warranted a segment in and of itself at
this point Alex trip we're familiar with
Alex Jones we have too many important
things going on to devote an entire
segment to Alex but a lot of posts on
the subreddit about this indeed it seems
that Alex Jones had been as from what we
know right now Alex Jones had been
drinking heavily um was involved in a
disturbance with his wife left driving
the wife had called the police the
police track down Alex Jones pulled him
over he was apparently drunk and he has
been arrested and not really a surprise
when we previously would talk about Alex
Jones and actually speak to people
including his ex-wife every indication
if you sort of understand what's going
on with this guy would lead you just
like we've been saying with George
Zimmerman when George Zimmerman was
acquitted in the killing of Trayvon
Martin we knew he'd continue having
problems with the law he's just that
type of guy and he has and no surprise
whatever about what Alex Jones is now
going through also a post from tofu
fighter on the subreddit tofu fighters
fighter says I'm really glad David is
speaking to us like adults there are a
ton of people on YouTube and Twitter
left that have been selling us false
hope there is still hope that Bernie
will pull off a miracle in what appears
to be the final days of the primary but
the numbers are not on our side there
really needs to be some self-reflection
with the progressive movement and where
we can go from here I've noticed a shift
from some folks online but there is
still a bernie was perfect and could do
no wrong and if you think any
differently you are a wrecker mentality
on Twitter and the YouTube left yeah I
mean listen if you want to see this in
action look at the number of dislikes on
my videos about the primary from
Wednesday this week the videos dated
March 11th and look at my look at my
Twitter page but look at with my replies
like actually click over to show tweets
and replies and you'll see the
back-and-forth and an
there are people who just don't want to
accept that a lot of the Democratic
electorate didn't like Bernie Sanders
they say well no they liked Bernie but
they voted for someone else anyway okay
maybe some but this is this is that's -
we will not win if that's your
explanation that explanation believing
that explanation will keep you from
actually dealing with what it is that's
going on but I appreciate that
some people have reached out and said
David I'm glad you're covering this like
you are because it needs to be covered
in this way lastly the winter mood
posted on the subreddit is trump for
venting coronavirus tests from being
released if you had asked me a week ago
I would have said it's crazy but then I
heard Trump say I don't need to have the
numbers double because of one ship that
wasn't our fault and it wasn't the fault
of the people on the ship either Trump
added it wasn't their fault either and
they're mostly Americans so I can live
either way with it I'd rather have them
stay on but I fully understand if they'd
rather take them off so yeah there's no
Trump knows that if we start widespread
testing the number of cases is going to
go up dramatically some estimates say
there are realistically between three
and eight thousand cases in the United
States right now I actually would be
reassured if the number of cases were
eight thousand only because it would
signal a much lower death rate the death
rate in the US right now based on the
number of cases that have been confirmed
is very very high it does not smoke bode
well for the United States if indeed
there are six five you know for eight
thousand cases right now we have a very
low death rate it would be reassuring
but Donald Trump just is thinking about
optics politics and all sorts of stuff
that doesn't really help anybody
actually deal with what's going on of
join the discussion on the David Pakman
show reddit at david pakman.com slash
our IDI di t